We're on problem 16.
And they want to know what is
the area of the shaded square?
Let me shade it because they
call it shaded square.
So what's that area?
So how can we do it?
Well, it's a bit of a trick, but
what you need to realize
is, you could draw-- Let me draw
some things that might--
This is actually a really
fun problem.
Let me draw some interesting
rectangles here.
Let me draw a rectangle there.
Let me draw another rectangle
there to there.
This really is just kind
of a brain teaser.
Draw another rectangle
from there to there.
And then let me draw another
rectangle from there to there.
OK, so let me ask you
a couple of things.
One: what is the distance of
the base of this rectangle
right here?
This distance.
Well, we know this entire--
whoops, wrong tool-- we know
this entire distance
is 3, right?
Because they tell us-- oh,
they don't even tell us.
They tell us that this
distance is this 1.
So we know that this
is a cube, right?
That this distance is 3.
So this distance is 1.
And then this distance
down here is 3.
And they tell us that this is
a shaded square, right?
So all the sides of this
inner shape are also
going to be the same.
So if this is 1, this
is 2, this is also
going to be 2, right?
That's going to be 2, that's
going to be 1, that's going to
be 1, this is going
to be 2, 1.
I think you get when
I'm saying, right?
And what is the distances
of the smaller
square inside of here?
Well, if this distance is 1,
this distance is 1 from here
to here, this distance
is also going to be 1
because 1 plus 1 is 2.
That's 1.
Same reason, you can make
the same argument.
This is 1, this is
1, this is 1.
So the area of this small square
inside, what's the area
of that small square?
What's the area of the magenta
square that I just filled in?
Well that area is
going to be 1.
right?
The magenta square is 1.
So now all we have to figure
out is the area of these 4
yellow triangles.
And what are the areas of each
of those yellow triangles?
Well, each of those yellow
triangles are-- they have a
dimension, on the long side,
the dimension is 2.
Let me find a good color.
On the long side, the dimension
is 2, right?
This distance right here is 2.
And on the short side,
the distance is 1.
So its area, each yellow
triangle is 2 times 1 times
1/2, right?
Because area of a triangle
is area equals
1/2 base times height.
So area of each of those
triangles is going to be 1/2
times 2 times 1, so that
equals 1, right?
So the area of this triangle
is 1, the area of this
triangle is 1, the area of this
triangle is 1, the area
of this triangle is 1.
And then the area of the square
inside is also 1.
So it's 1 plus 1 plus
1 plus 1 plus 1.
The total area is 5.
Area equals 5, that
was pretty neat.
And the big thing you need to
realize is that you can split
up the square on the
inside like this.
Let me think if there
was another way.
That's the way that
it occurred to me.
Maybe there's another way, maybe
I'm over-complicating
it, I don't know.
But it looks nice.
Next problem.
For all positive integers, j
and k, let j-- I like these
where they define new math
operations-- j square with an
r inside of it, k, be defined as
the whole number remainder
when j is divided by k.
So this equals remainder
If you're familiar with the
concept of a modulus, that's
essentially what this
operation is.
If 13-- I guess we'll call this
remainder operation-- k
is equal to 2, what
is the value of k?
And they tell us in the
beginning that j and k, all of
these things have to be positive
numbers, right?
So this is essentially saying
that when I divide 13 by some
positive number, I get
a remainder of 2.
Well, what number when I
divide it into 13 is 2?
I guess another way to think
about it is 13 minus 2 is a
multiple of this
number, right?
So you could say, what's
13 minus 2?
Well it's 11.
So 11 is a multiple of k, and
actually 11 should be k
because if 11's a multiple of k,
and 11's not a multiple of
much, right?
Eleven's only a multiple of 1
and 11, so k has to be 11.
And you can test it out.
I mean, if you get confused,
just try
out different numbers.
13 divided by 11 is equal
to one, right?
Because 11 goes in
13 one time.
Remainder 2.
Which satisfies this.
13 remainder 11 is equal to 2.
Next problem.
Problem 18.
The average of the test
scores of a class of
p students is 70.
The average is 70, so what
do we know about that?
We know that if we were to add
up all of the p students--
well, actually, let me read the
rest of the problem before
I do anything.
And the average of the test
scores of a class of n
students is 92.
When the scores of both classes
are combined, the
average score is 86.
What is the value of p/n?
OK, so what is the sum of
the p student scores?
So their average is 70, so the
sum of all of their scores is
going to be 70p, right?
You can take the average
and multiply it by
the number of students.
And then you get the sum of all
of their scores, right?
And if that doesn't make a lot
of sense, think about it.
What's the definition
of average?
It's the sum divided by p is
equal to the average, right?
So if you multiply both sides by
p, you get the sum is equal
to p times the average.
In this case, the
average is 70.
So 70 times p is the sum of
the first class, and then
what's the sum of the
second class?
It's going to be 92n for
the same exact reason.
And now, how many total students
are we averaging?
Well there are p in this sum and
there are n in this sum,
so it's p plus n, and they
tell us that this average
score is 86.
So we set up our equation
and now let's solve.
Let's multiply both sides by p
plus n, so you get 70p plus
92n is equal to 86p plus 86n,
right? p plus n times 86,
distribute the 86.
Now what do we want to do?
We eventually want to figure out
p/n, so let's put the n's
on the left-hand side.
So I'm going to subtract 86n
from both sides, so you get
70p plus-- 92 minus 86 is 6n
is equal to 86p, right?
I subtracted this from
the other side.
And then let's subtract 70p from
both sides, so you get 6n
is equal to 16p, right?
86 minus 70.
And then we want to know p/n.
So we divide both sides by n,
you get 6 is equal to 16p/n
and now divide both sides
by 16, and you get
6/16 is equal to p/n.
And, of course, we
can reduced 6/16.
6/16 is the same thing as 3/8.
That is our answer for p/n.
I'll see you in the
next section.